Look at this set of numbers.
Twelve, sixteen, twelve, six, eighteen, two and four.
Let's find out the arithmetic mean of these numbers first.
We know that it equals the sum of values
divided by the number of values.
The sum of values would be 12 plus 16 plus 12 plus
6 plus 18 plus 2 plus 4.
And there are 1, 2, 3 ,4, 5, 6 & 7.
7 values.
We divide this sum by 7.
12 plus 16 is 28,
28 plus 12 is 40,
40 plus 6 is 46,
46 plus 18 is 64,
and 64 plus 6 is 70.
So the mean would equal 70 divided by 7.
That gives us 10.
So the mean of these seven numbers is 10.
What we are basically doing is finding an approximate central value
of a given set of values.
So there are a couple of other ways to find the central value.
To understand them,
we first need to arrange the values in ascending order,
from the least number to the highest number.
'2' as we can see is the least number.
We write a '2' first.
The next higher number is '4'.
We write a '4' next.
Then '6',
it is always a good idea to mark the numbers you have written
with a pencil.
If the list is huge,
there is a chance that you might miss out a few numbers.
So '6' would come next
the next highest number after '6' is '12'.
And it occurs twice.
So we write '12' and '12' here.
Then '16' then '18'.
We write '16' and '18' and that completes our list.
Make sure you have covered all values.
Arranging it in an ascending order
gives us something called the 'median'.
The median is the middle value of the list
when it's arranged in ascending order.
There are seven values we have here.
And we can see that '12' is the middle value.
So the median of this set of values is '12'.
The median is just another way to measure the central tendency.
So the mean is the average,
and the median is the middle value.
But only after we have arranged the terms in ascending order.
And the third concept is that of a mode.
It is the value that occurs more frequently.
In our list we can see that '12' occurs twice.
And all other numbers occur just once.
So the mode of this set of values is '12'.
Why do we have three concepts to know the central tendency ?
Isn't one enough?
What are the applications of each?
All these questions will be answered in the coming videos.